Master Yaddle is right about one thing
Sith Lord is not to be trifled with but
the wisdom of the council is to be
cautious until we know more but I
will protect you my old padawan. Obi-Wan fills
that role now he acquits himself quite well
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is my full
Star Wars tales of the Jedi episode video they
released all the shorts at the same time their
six episodes there's a bunch of new Easter eggs
and reveals that we have to talk about so be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos we're almost
at the end of and or season one right now in the
next Big Star Wars thing will be the Mandalorian
season 3 episodes in February next year and right
after that the Ahsoka episodes so no coincidence
that like a big part of tales of the Jedi was
about them filling in missing parts of ahsoka's
backstory I've already done big videos of the
Mandalorian season 3 trailer the Ahsoka trailer
so I'll post links for both of those at the end
of this and down in the description below the
other big part of the series was mostly dedicated
to Count Dooku's Untold backstory like it was all
this missing history all these missing details
for both Dooku and Ahsoka so it was really cool
master
I always love having morrisoka's stuff she's
one of the best Star Wars characters of all time
Rosario Dawson has been awesome as the live-action
version so far and what little we've seen of her
in live action cannot wait for the full Ahsoka
episodes when it starts the next year but I
actually enjoyed the Dooku parts of tales of the
Jedi even more learning more about his backstory
because he's this really important character in
the story just in general in all of Star Wars but
we've only gotten pieces of his backstory so far
like he was heavily featured during the Clone Wars
Episodes but that was much later in his timeline
after he'd gone full Darth tyrannus evil and he
was much more like he was during attack of the
Clones we never really seen his life before he
turned to the dark side became the emperor's next
Sith Apprentice like what was his life like before
he became evil so we'll start with all the Dooku
parts of the tales of the Jedi series first then
I'll talk about the Ahsoka Parts what we learned
about Count Dooku's story is that he originally
is from the planet Serenia he was from a Noble
House thus the title account Count Dooku but
as a child he was abandoned by his family and
taken in by the Jedi Order when they learned
that he was force sensitive he was born during the
high Republic era they're actually trying to make
that a big thing in live action now like the next
Big Star Wars series they're working on is a high
Republic Sith series but it's more of like a sis
series set during the high Republic era so like
we might see a young version of Palpatine a much
younger version of Yoda maybe a very very young
version of Dooku just depending on where it picks
up exactly in the timeline but Dooku as you've
seen in live action in The Clone Wars and now
entails of the Jedi was a very formal person he
was raised inside the nobility so those mannerisms
the personality just the way that a noble person
carries themselves in the Star Wars Universe kind
of stayed through him through his entire life as
opposed to Classic Farm Boy Luke Skywalker like
very blue-collar attitude way of speaking until
he fully became a Jedi Knight inserted on the
path to creating his Jedi Temple and training
people like Roku briefly training grogu once Luke
Skywalker became a Jedi Knight he became a much
more formal person we learned Dooku's Padawan
was Qui-Gon Jinn himself even though they use a
different voice actor in episode 2 for the young
version of his character Liam Neeson did come
back to do the voice for the older Qui-Gon Jinn in
episode 4 after he'd become a Jedi master and has
started training Obi-Wan Kenobi Dooku's timeline
during all of his episodes start when Qui-Gon was
very young like long before the events of Phantom
Menace In The Clone Wars and then end right before
attack of the Clones in his episodes are meant to
show how Count Dooku slowly became disillusioned
with the Jedi Order the Republic itself on
a political level like at least him turning
away from those things initially was more of a
political thing it didn't become personal till
much much later which I'll talk about but it's
meant to explain why he created the separatist
movement like why politically he was opposed to
what the Republic was doing how he'd seen that
they'd grown corrupt even though obviously what
Palpatine did was very terrible they wanted to
show you that even despite all that the Republic
was still a little bit rotten they show you why he
turned away from the Jedi Order and approached
Palpatine to become his next Sith Apprentice
because he'd seen that the Jedi Order looked like
they were also just becoming tools of this corrupt
Republic and that's actually a big thing that
George Lucas talked about like they wanted to show
the fallacy of the Jedi Order how they'd gotten
to ingrained in their ways too stubborn that's
actually one of the major reasons why Count Dooku
turned away from them and blames them for Qui-Gon
jinn's death because during Phantom Menace they
refused they refused to believe that there could
be another Sith Lord in another Sith Apprentice
like no no that's not a problem don't think about
that don't worry about it cut to a little bit
later Qui-Gon Jin dies at the hands of Darth Maul
so you could actually call Count Dooku's storyline
during tales of the Jedi the tragedy of Count
Dooku the wise you ever hear the tragedy of
Darth Plagueis the whites everyone post all
the Palpatine memes again is basically the story
of the fall of Count Dooku he was this very good
Jedi Master very powerful very wise but he saw
the flaws and the Jedi ordered the Injustice in
the Galaxy it wanted to fix that on a political
level which is why he created the separatist
movement but they do explain that he didn't want a
giant War he didn't want to kill a bunch of people
he didn't have evil intentions he didn't want
to kill the Jedi either he just opposed their
Viewpoint that's why I say it was more of a
political thing for him and less of a personal
thing it didn't become personal until the death
of Qui-Gon Jinn but you have to remember that
Palpatine is manipulating him this whole time the
way that he manipulates all of his apprentices and
everyone around him like he manipulated Darth Maul
to his own ends he manipulated Anakin Skywalker so
even though Count Dooku had the best of intentions
the story is basically the fall of Count Dooku in
Palpatine manipulating him pushing him towards
the dark side forcing him to do all these evil
things like he forces Count Dooku to kill Master
yaddle basically which is also the other big
reveal of the series they found finally explain
what happened to master yaddle now there's a
real life explainer like what really happened and
why she didn't come back in the prequels and then
there's the way they explain it inside the Canon
because she's on the Jedi Council during Phantom
Menace that was the first time she ever showed up
in the Canon George Lucas introduced the character
then and then we never saw her again after that
the real reason why yaddle didn't come back and
attacking the Clones is because George Lucas just
kind of changed his mind about using the character
like you know what I want Yoda to feel more unique
more special I only want one of him on screen we
don't need a second version of Yoda so it was more
about him just backtracking on his use of other
beings of Yoda's race and then they just never
addressed that in the rest of the movies like
they just never talk about yaddle ever again so
like a lot of Star Wars things like the movies do
something big and then the time material attempts
to explain all the gaps in the logic there were
some Comics at the time that tried to explain what
happened to yaddle but now this new tales of the
Jedi story is the new Full Canon backstory for
what happened to her they revealed that Qui-Gon
jinn's death broke Count Dooku he was his Padawan
so of course he felt very close to him even though
he long since stopped being his Padawan Obi-Wan
fills that role now I should like to meet him
someday always singing races it's a great pity
that our paths have never crossed before Obi-Wan
Qui-Gon always spoke very highly of you and
that was the major turning point for him where
he really committed to the separatists movement
in the Sith more so this Sith because obviously
he killed Master yaddle he blamed the Jedi Council
for qui-gon's death because they refused to listen
to him about the threat of Darth Maul in a
lot of the first part of the episode takes
place during Phantom Menace if that wasn't clear
like it's right after Qui-Gon Jin has come back
to Coruscant with Anakin Skywalker informed the
Jedi Council about what happened on Tatooine with
Darth Maul so it's like right after that meeting
and it's why yaddle is saying well you know the
council we're trying to be cautious we don't want
to alert everybody alarm everyone before we know
what's really going on but then they explained
that yaddle is actually one of the few people
who actually realized the turmoil that was going
on inside Count Dooku and generally tried to help
him after the fact she left her post on the
Jedi Council because she also too felt like
the Jedi Council was wrong and she tries to have
a similar conversation with him that say like Yoda
in Obi-Wan Kenobi has with Anakin Skywalker this
whole idea about the role of fear in how Palpatine
is using their fears against them pushing them to
the dark side so like this is a big parallel for
what happened to Anakin Skywalker as well so
if it wasn't clear yaddle is meant to be dead
he's meant to have killed her and that's meant to
take place right before the events of attack of
the Clones like this place is also shown in the
prequel movies where they meet I think after he
actually killed her is when Emperor Palpatine
named him Darth taranus like when he gave him
his Sith name during his storyline they also
kind of throw Mace Windu under the bus just a
little bit too they make it seem like he was more
of a political player playing The Game of Thrones
so to speak just trying to get a position on the
council like you knew about this the whole time
you were just positioning yourself for his seat on
the council so they really want you to sympathize
with Count Dooku and just show how he was taken
advantage of his Fall From Grace and how Palpatine
took advantage of that basically that's why I
say the tragedy of Count Dooku the wise and if
you guys didn't realize that yaddle was actually
voiced by Bryce Dallas Howard obviously she was
doing a very different type of voice and the other
big surprise too with yaddle's appearance is that
she talks totally normal I guess when it travels
fast wow or statements to the council will rather
surprising it turns out the rest of their race
doesn't speak like Yoda in that backwards way
which I actually think is a good move on Star Wars
part just treating the Canon that way it's another
way to make Yoda feel like a very unique type of
character even though his race is so rare in the
Galaxy like now we have grogu it also lets you
know that grogu is probably going to speak more
like yaddle in more normal type of way once he
eventually does start speaking I wouldn't even
be surprised if he can speak right now like he's
over 50 years old so he's probably capable of
speaking some types of words he just chooses not
to in speaking of grogu I know a lot of you are
asking is yaddle really grogu's mother is Yoda
his father now I think that they're probably
not even though their race is super rare There are
rules about whether or not Jedi can have children
obviously a big thing with Anakin Skywalker and
Padme but the Jedi Order had special contingency
rules for Yoda's race and other races of low
numbers Kia Mundi is a really good example of
this where they allow Jedi to have children if
their race was at danger of becoming extinct so
technically by the rules of the Jedi Order just
canonically it would have been okay for Yoda
and yaddle to have a child either separately or
together the reason why I don't think that Yoda
and yaddle are grogu's parents is because they
want grogu as a character just to function within
the Canon is a completely new entity his parents
are just meant to be random members of Yoda's
race from somewhere out in the Deep Galaxy and
honestly I don't think that they want to reveal
that for a long long time like a week ago 50 years
without them fully revealing who grogu's parents
actually are I think that they would do it that
way George Lucas was notoriously protective of
the Yoda character which is one of the reasons
why he got rid of yaddle in the Canon he also
prevented a lot of people that were doing the
books and the comics and the time material from
over explaining Yoda like he didn't want them
writing a bunch of new backstory for Yoda just
because he felt like it was more powerful that the
character was still such a mystery which I think
John Favreau and Dave floony are sort of carrying
forward with the grogu character like they want
him to be as mysterious as possible then talking
about the Ahsoka story during tales of the Jedi
we learned all about her backstory her birth her
family and then a little bit that ties in with
the events of Revenge of the Sith in the Clone
Wars season 7 at the end so it kind of covers
her entire timeline which is filling in a couple
major gaps like where did she come from how did
she wind up in the Jedi Order and what happened
right after Revenge of the Sith after she crashed
on that planet at the end of Clone Wars season
seven she's from the took Ruda race her home
planet is shilly her mother is named pav T and
she's actually voiced by Janina gavankar who also
played Iden versio during the Battlefront games
we learned more about her biology her race like
we see a bunch of other people of her race that
obviously looked very different we learned that
the White markings on her face aren't tattoos they
aren't makeup either they're just like naturally
part of her skin that evolve and grow over time
with the rest of her body is the same thing too
for her head tails those are called their lekku
like they all have them but they're all unique to
each different member of their race they explain
how her mother her people learned that she was
force sensitive she was about a year old during
the events of the episode when the lion brings
her back she winds up saving her herself basically
using the force but she didn't actually get taken
to the Jedi Temple till she was about three years
old so like a little bit of time goes by and it
was Plo Koonwho brought her to the Jedi Temple plo
koon's mask is actually inside Lutheran's shop in
the Star Wars Andor series after the events of
Revenge of the Sith the events of episode 5 Star
earlier in the Clone Wars when she was much
younger she's still relatively new to being
Anakin's Padawan and he wants to train her to be
a better Jedi by doing a lot of unconventional
types of training with the other clones the whole
title of the episode is practice makes perfect so
they have this big Montage that covers a bunch
of years through the Clone Wars where she just
keeps getting knocked out keeps getting a little
bit better a little bit better that's why at the
beginning of the Montage she only has the one
lightsaber but she's using the twin lightsabers
later because later she got twin lightsabers
during her adventures in the Clone Wars and
this was all with the purpose of training her
to be a better Jedi just in general a better
Warrior better at protecting herself protecting
other people which they later pay off during this
scene at the end taking place right in the middle
of Order 66 right at the end of the Clone Wars
season 7 because the whole idea with the Clone
Wars season 7 is that that final Arc was meant
to show you the events of Revenge of this from
ahsoka's perspective in the clone's perspective
so like you're witnessing Order 66 while you're
amongst all the Clones in Ahsoka Wallace happening
training that she because here's the practice
makes perfect to survive all these clones that
want her dead because of order 66. there's a
little bit of a time Jump for the very last
episode episode 6. it's meant to cover the
time right after Revenge of the Sith after
she's left the planet she goes back to Naboo
for padme's funeral and explains how she gets
involved with bail Organa in the Rebellion so
during the Rebellion Ahsoka used this code name
called fulcrum and she served as sort of a
lone gun going around helping people where
they needed it in the outer rim mostly to stay
off the emperor and Darth Vader's radar but she
also served as the point of communications between
Rebel cells so early in the Rebellion before they
actually came together before the events of Rogue
one and a new hope there were all these different
disparate cells across the galaxy in the way
they communicated with each other was to use
a go-between in Ahsoka was that go between so
for instance during Andor when we're seeing the
Rebellion come together when luthin is listening
on the rebel radio communications technically
he'd be listening to Ahsoka communicating Rebel
activity from other cells so like Ahsoka is kind
of involved in the events of Andor without
literally being on the show they show right
after padme's death how she kind of gave up
and tried to go to ground in the outer rim in
a lot of these events are actually covered in the
Ahsoka book that they released a couple years ago
like the plot is Loosely based on the plot of
that Ahsoka book she goes to ground and tries
to live this simple existence kind of doing what
grogu did not using their Jedi abilities as much
as possible also kind of what Obi-Wan Kenobi did
where we see him at the beginning of the Obi-Wan
Kenobi series but eventually someone learns
that she's Jedi and forms of Sith inquisitors
and this particular Inquisitor is called the
sixth brother his real name is Bil Valen the
reason why you don't see him during the Obi-Wan
Kenobi series is because Ahsoka kills him before
that series takes place even though there's a
small time Jump between episode 5 and episode
6 this is meant to take place really close after
the events of Revenge of the Sith like not a lot
of time has gone by overall the series was great
love the stuff that they did the animation was
on point Dave filoni always does great things I
think he wrote all the episodes himself my only
minor complaint like real minor complaint is that
they burned the title tales of the Jedi on this
and Anthology series and didn't actually do what
tales of the Jedi Knights of the Old Republic
types of series like I would have rather them
used the title tales of the Jedi to do an actual
Old Republic series we'll see if they ever do that
they seems like they really want to do more with
the high Republic era than they want to do with
the Knights of the Old Republic era but if you
spotted any other easter eggs or references in
the episode or anything I didn't cover in this
video just write it below in the comments and
I'll try to address it everyone click here for
my full Mandalorian Season 3 trailer video and
click here for my new house of the dragon season
2 video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!